how are you both doing
great how are you steve how are you
doing man
i am doing i am doing well uh you know
paul's in his usual backdrop of a green
screen um
i'm sure five days a week for you
yeah this is nothing i didn't even have
to leave
i could have just i could be on set
right now
that's what i mean
what you can put a ghost behind me or an
ant
i i was literally going to say peyton
reed is actually to your left and he is
jason reitman and he's they're giving
you direction
right yeah i don't know which way to
turn ready
so let me start by saying congrats on
the movie i had a blast with it i hope
it's a huge hit um seriously you guys
are great in it um i love learning about
the behind the scenes of the making of
movies what do you guys what do you want
fans to know what do you think would
surprise people to learn about the
making of the film
oh surprise people well i hope they
appreciate and and can tell that there's
so many practical effects in the film it
really feels like a kind of film that
doesn't get made anymore it's certainly
a kind of film that i wouldn't get to
make it feels like even the titles are
hand cut they even got the original i
think titleist to make the titles so um
i think you can feel that i think you
can feel how tangible the world is that
we're playing in
um
which i think is really special you just
don't get that anymore right paul
greenscreen paul yeah yeah that was one
thing that i think when i first saw it
um
that i just i loved so much about it is
that it reminded me of movies i saw when
i was a kid that
um
even carrie i was thinking like there's
that scene even though you're starting
and you're talking to
finn and he's cutting his hair and you
seem like a kind of a frazzled mom and
mckenna's at the outlet and and the way
the sound design is where there's
dialogue it's not played for laughs or
anything and people are talking over one
another and i thought
that could be jo beth williams i mean
it's like it had this feeling of like oh
my god this is like it's
it feels like uh
like i've seen like a like a spielberg
feel to it or or um
you know like an ambulance there was
there was something kind of
there was
there was something uh
nostalgic even outside of the
ghostbusters
yeah that really kind of took me back
in a way that
i i was unprepared for when i first saw
it and i i thought i really don't think
i'm going to be alone in thinking this
um other people that see this or it will
remind them of going to the movies in
the 80s and in the 90s and
having some of those experiences yeah
yeah no jason definitely crafted like an
ambulan-esque 80s film oh that's right
100
for each of you guys
uh there's always a shot or shots that
are a real pain in the ass in every
movie what was the shot in this movie
for both of you uh that was like man
that this is a tough day
the ending for me was the hardest part
because they took that they had that
house they built it out in calgary and
they planted a field and all that stuff
and then they took that set and put it
inside into a studio but they brought
all the dirt
from the dirt field and then they blew
dirt at us with giant fans for about two
and a half weeks that was the hardest
part for me i was crouched in dirt in a
skirt for two and a half weeks
[Laughter]
you know there's this
sequence
that uh
i did at a like a
in a department store
um you do you want to name walmart or no
oh can't it wasn't it was right
in the movies walmart yeah yeah so um
anyway i i there's a lot of running
around and stuff like that and and there
were certain things about that none of
it was like that hard but there was
there is one shot where i'm running kind
of full speed and i had to jump up onto
the hood of my car and slide through the
windshield which had been smashed out
into the front seat and land a certain
way
and uh to do that several times
um
was
was one of the more challenging things
uh without
impaling myself like on a gear shift
right i was going to make a joke about
green screen but um i i actually do want
to ask one individual question paul
it's an ant-man thing but uh so venom
might be joining the mcu based on this
new venom the ending of the venom movie
are you excited for venom to possibly be
a friend of ant-man or an enemy of
ant-man i haven't even i haven't seen
the new venom movie so i don't even know
you might know more than me
i don't know the idea of it
you know the idea i i uh
i don't know what i don't know what to
tell you yeah
i want everybody to be friends it's just
my way it's just the way i feel about
life
i understand listen congrats on the
movie i gotta stop uh i really do hope
it's a huge hit for you guys and uh
thank you for your time
thank you take care cool thanks